we begin with an update now from the
i-team a valley family calling for
answers tonight in their son's death the
unlv student was taken to sunrise
hospital last week after collapsing at a
fraternity boxing match his family tells
us he could not survive those severe
brain injuries it is a story the i-team
broke first here on 8 news now vanessa
murphy continues her coverage this
evening
nathan valencia's family and attorney
say a fraternity boxing match held here
at the sahara event center cost the
student his life they tell the i-team he
was a healthy 20-year-old who
participated for charity and they
believe a lack of precautions taken at
the event led to his death it should
have been done correctly it shouldn't
have been overlooked to lose someone so
precious like that it's hard xavier dela
rosa says he's known nathan valencia
since their days at bishop gorman high
school nathan then moving on to unlv and
becoming a member of sigma alpha epsilon
[Music]
on november 19th he participated in this
boxing match held by another unlv
fraternity kappa sigma he collapsed
after the fight
a family attorney tells the i-team no
medical help was immediately available
and it appears there was no professional
referee a formal statement from the
family and their legal team reads in
part college students should not be
placed in a situation where they are
pitted against each other for combat
kappa sigma fight night is an event that
has been held annually and was well
known to both unlv and the national
kappa sigma fraternity a spokesman for
unlv tells the i-team the university is
actively looking into the incident like
this this thing
it's like an underground fight club joe
castro is a friend of nathan's who was
there event itself didn't seem very
organized but i saw no medical medic
no doctors no nothing we reached out to
the kappa sigma fraternity and we
received a statement about condolences
for nathan's family and the unlv
community we also reached out to the
sahara event center they also sent a
statement about condolences the family's
attorney tells me metro police are
investigating reporting in las vegas
vanessa murphy live local now
unlv's president dr keith whitfield sent
the campus community a message about
nathan valencia's death earlier today we
have that along with complete statements
and the link to a gofundme for medical
and funeral expenses it's all on our
website at 8newsnow.com